now the government has decided to push
ahead with plans to privatize the
broadcaster channel for our chief
political correspondent as you can see
john craig is here so uh john what's
happening i mean this has been around
for for a long while and some thought it
might have actually calmed cool down a
bit well um
it goes back to when gordon brown was
chancellor he was talking about
privatizing channel four it raised a
billion pounds uh so it's attractive to
the chancellor what's happened tonight
is that the government has confirmed
that it is going to press ahead put a
bill in the queen's speech a draft bill
the government's saying there's an all
already a big row with labour accusing
the government of vandalism cultural
vandalism says lucy powell the shadow
secretary of state for culture nadine
doris of course uh big johnson
cheerleader and loyalist
and uh she will be uh delighted uh
licking her lips probably at the
prospect of privatizing channel 4 news
some of her critics say she'd probably
quite like to privatize the bbc as well
but uh in the government is saying that
it's going to pursue a sale of channel 4
as part of a package of reforms to
modernize and sustain the uk's public
service broadcasting sector the
government is saying
that government ownership is holding
channel 4 back in the face of a rapidly
changing and competitive media landscape
but there's already a row with labour
hitting out at this
at the weekend a new boss of a chairman
of channel 4 news was appointed he's
surrey and cheshire a retail uh tycoon
and the tories were claiming accusing
the government of cronyism there because
he's
been
close to david cameron been on as i
recall foreign trips with him to uh um
business and no end business trips with
the former prime minister so it looks as
though there's going to be a big media
battle here between those who are
dead set on privatization like uh nadine
doris like the former media minister
john whittingdale he was always a great
supporter of it and the labour party uh
who are dead against it in their
reaction tonight channel 4 has said the
proposal to privatize channel four will
require a lengthy legislative progress
and political debate what they're
suggesting probably is that in the house
of lords it'll come up against
opposition and yes i'm sure they're
right about that there will be a big
debate in parliament about it